So to show you an example of what that
looks like, we've created a test page that's in udacity.com
cs101 index.html and when we run get all links
we'll see all the links on that page. Let me
show you what the page is first. This is
our test page for learning to crawl. So that's the
URL that we're using to get page and get all
links from that page. Now you see that this page
has three links on it. The first one goes to
crawling.html, the second one goes to walking.html, and the third
one goes to flying.html. We'll look soon at the structure
of these pages when we do our web crawler. You can
try that on your own in the web browser. For
now, what we are interested in is finding these three links.
So when we assign links for the result to get
all links. We can print the value of links that we
get back. And when we run that, we see a list
containing the three links on the page. And because that is a
list, well, we can do useful things with it. We could
extract the value at position zero, and get just the first link
on the page. So think on your own, if you could
define get all links. If you're ambitious, you'll try to define this
all by yourself. We're going to step through how to do this with
a few quizzes because I think it's quite a challenging thing to
do all by yourself. But think about that by yourself first,
and then we'll step through it with a series of quizzes.